Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We'll start with a quick recap on Metropolis
Light Transport and then discuss a cool technique
that builds on top of it.
If we would like to see how digitally modeled
objects would look like in real life, we would
create a 3D model of the desired scene, assign
material models to the objects within, and
use a photorealistic rendering algorithm to
finish the job. It simulates rays of light
that connect the camera to the light sources
in the scene and compute the flow of energy
between them.
Initially, after a few rays, we'll only have
a rough idea on how the image should look
like, therefore our initial results will contain
a substantial amount of noise. We can get
rid of this by simulating the path of millions
and millions of rays that will eventually
clean up our image. This process, where a
noisy image gets clearer and clearer, we call
convergence, and the problem is that this
can take excruciatingly long, even up to hours
to get a perfectly clear image.
With the simpler algorithms out there, we
generate these light paths randomly. This
technique we call path tracing. However, in
the scene that you see here, most random paths
can't connect the camera and the light source
because this wall is in the way, obstructing
many of them. Light paths like these don't
contribute anything to our calculations and
are ultimately a waste of time and resources.
After generating hundreds of random light
paths, we have found a path that finally connects
the camera with the light source without any
obstructions. When generating the next path,
it would be a crime to not use this knowledge
to our advantage. A technique called
Metropolis Light Transport will make sure to use this
valuable knowledge, and upon finding a bright
light path, it will explore other paths that
are nearby, to have the best shot at creating
valid, unobstructed connections.
If we have a difficult scene at hand, Metropolis Light Transport gives us way better results
than traditional, completely random path sampling
techniques, such as path tracing.
This scene is extremely difficult in a sense
that the only source of light is coming from
the upper left, and after the light goes through
multiple glass spheres, most of the light
paths that we generate will be invalid. As
you can see, this is a valiant effort with
random path tracing that yields really dreadful
results. Metropolis Light Transport is extremely
useful in these cases and therefore should
always be the weapon of choice.
However, it is more expensive to compute than
traditional random sampling. This means that
if we have an easy scene on our hands, this
smart Metropolis sampling doesn't pay off
and performs worse than a naive technique
in the same amount of time.
So, on easy scenes, traditional random sampling,
difficult scenes, Metropolis sampling. Super
simple, super intuitive, but the million dollar
question is how to mathematically formulate
and measure what an easy and what a difficult
scene is.
This problem is considered extremely difficult
and was left open in the Metropolis Light Transport
paper in 2002.
Even if we knew what to look for, we would
likely get an answer by creating a converged
image of the scene, which, without the knowledge
of what algorithm to use, may take up to days
to complete. But if we've created the image,
it's too late, so we would need this information
before we start this rendering process. This
way we can choose the right algorithm on the
first try.
With this technique that came more than ten
years after the Metropolis paper, it is possible
to mathematically formalize and quickly decide
whether a scene is easy or difficult. The
key insight is that in a difficult scene we
often experience that a completely random
ray is very likely to be invalid. This insight,
with two other simple metrics gives us all
the knowledge we need to decide whether a
scene is easy or difficult, and the algorithm
tells us what mixture of the two sampling
techniques we exactly need to use to get beautiful
images quickly.
The more complex light transport algorithms
get, the more efficient they become, but at
the same time, we're wallowing in parameters
that we need to set up correctly to get adequate
results quickly. This way, we have an algorithm
that doesn't take any parameters. You just
fire it up, and forget about it. Like a good
employee, it knows when to work smart, and
when a dumb solution with a lot of firepower
is better. And, it was tested on a variety
of scenes and found close to optimal settings.
Implementing this technique is remarkably
easy, someone who is familiar with the basics
of light transport can do it in less than
half an hour.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!